PROTOCOL, BUT HE'S BACK AND HEE
THE LINEUP FRIDAY THE OPENING S
OF THIS GAME, SASAD AND KREIDER
LALA THEHE
LONG PASS,
AS A HEAD COACH IN THE NHL.
RUSH OFF.
FOX WILL BE THE ONLY PLAYER IN
FRONT, AND SO NOW HE'S G BACK.
TROUBA FOR ON THIS PASS RIGHT
THERE.
INTERCEPTS IT AND THEN A LITTLE
REAVES AS WELLS IT ORHIS CALGAR
THAT THEY ARE BRING ALONG, AND
FIRST POWER PLAY OF THE GAME.
>> Sam: TROUBA WAS GOING AT IT
THE WITH ANDREW
SCORES.
THE DEFENSEMAN COMING LATE. FIN
THE BENEN
NEMETH'S PASS TAKEN AWAY BY END.
CHYTIL TOK AND
PLAYAY
MILAN LUCIC AND TAKEN AWAY BY
ZIBANEJAD.
JOINED BY THE SHORTHANDED SHOT,.
ALL OVER
PLAYS.
GOODROW IN THE COPPER UNDER ALL
KINDS OF
127 LEFT IN THT COMES OVER.
SHOOT, SAVE, REBOUND AND DIRECT.
SHESTERKIN, BUT THEY SCORE ON
THE REBOUND.
BLAKEE COLEMAN BUT THEN THE
PUCK COMES RIGHT RISING SHOT BET
THROUGH THE NEUTRAL ZONE AND
BACKLUND FINDS A LITTLE MAKE ANT
.
MANGIAPANE.
WITH JUST UNDER
GETS IT BACK OUT